[Music]
welcome back so now I'm going to show
you one of the most useful properties of
the fast Fourier transform which is that
you can use it to compute very accurate
derivatives of clean data okay
so we're going to talk about the FFT and
derivatives and we've already seen
before that the regular Fourier
transform kind of the the analytic
Fourier transform can be used to compute
the derivatives of functions here we're
going to show that the fast Fourier
transform can be used to approximate
derivatives from discretely sampled data
okay so in this example we're going to
start with a function where we actually
know what the answer is so this our
function is going to be cosine x times e
to the minus x squared over 25 so it's
basically a cosine function in an
Gaussian decaying envelope okay and what
I'm gonna do is I know the analytic
derivative DF so I just computed this
using the chain rule so this is the true
derivative and what we're gonna do is
we're going to approximate the
derivative using a finite difference
derivative just kind of a forward
difference scheme so the next point
minus the last point divided by Delta X
and then I'm going to approximate the
derivative using the fast Fourier
transform and we're going to see that
the fast Fourier transform derivative is
much much more accurate than finite
difference now this is a very very crude
demonstration the first thing you might
be saying is well I know lots better
find out different schemes you could use
central difference you could use higher
order accurate schemes that use more
more points that's absolutely true
but what we're gonna find is that the
fast Fourier transform is going to be
kind of the best you can do
on clean data in terms of the derivative
okay so this is just meant to be an
illustration comparing the fast Fourier
transform derivative with the finite
difference derivative okay so I have a
true function f defined on some interval
I think from
- 15 - 15 so length 30 there's a hundred
and twenty eight data points so pretty
coarse and I know my analytic derivative
DF so I'm going to compare with that
okay so the finite difference derivative
is simple it's just kind of F we're
approximating f prime is approximately
this is an index K is approximately F
and index K plus 1 minus F K divided by
Delta X that's about as crude of an
approximation as you can get to the
derivative finite difference order Delta
X the error is going to be order Delta X
okay but with our fast Fourier transform
it's also very easy to compute the
derivative so remember if I have the
Fourier transform of the derivative of
my function with respect to X this is
equal to now sometimes I write this as I
times Omega Fourier transform but when I
Fourier transform with respect to space
sometimes I use Kappa so I'm just gonna
make a little note down here Kappa is
usually for space spatial frequencies
and Omega I'm gonna usually use for
temporal frequencies and they're
basically the same thing they're just
Fourier variables but if I a Fourier
transform a function of space I'm often
going to call the for a variable Kappa
which is a spatial frequency or a wave
number we call it a wave number a lot
whereas if I take a function of time and
I Fourier transform it then my for a
variable is going to be Omega and that's
gonna be a temporal frequency so I'm
just gonna
here I'm using Kappa it's it's often
common to use Kappa okay good so my
Fourier transform of a derivative is
just I times Kappa or I times Omega if
it's a time function times the Fourier
transform of F which is just f hat okay
so instead of computing the derivative I
can just compute the Fourier transform
and multiply that by I times Kappa okay
now the catch here
is that in the discrete or fast Fourier
transform this is a vector of Fourier
coefficients so I have to multiply each
element by that corresponding frequency
so this is actually a vector of spatial
frequencies and this is a vector of
Fourier coefficients and I have to
multiply them element wise to get a new
vector essentially you know kappa 1 f 1
hat kappa 2 f 2 hat and so on and so
forth all of this times i so that's how
i'm defining this this derivative using
the discrete Fourier transform I compute
a vector of frequencies Kappa I have my
vector of Fourier transform coefficients
F hat and I kind of dot multiply them
element wise to get this this new vector
of my derivatives and if I inverse
Fourier transform this quantity when I
inverse Fourier transform I'll recover
my derivative DF DX and what we're gonna
find is that this is actually very very
accurate okay so that's all we're doing
here is I'm creating a big vector of
frequencies in Kappa and this is kind of
a MATLAB trick a couple of lines you
need to know in MATLAB is that if you
define your fundamental frequency as 2
pi divided by L and you can have kind of
low frequencies and high frequencies as
a whole vector of frequencies you have
to do this fft shift command in matlab
which basically reorders this kappa
vector to be consistent with its
internal FFT ordering of the frequencies
I think this is kind of a mess every
language orders frequencies differently
like C++ orders in one way Python you
know and MATLAB will order them
differently and so in MATLAB this is
just AI remember this these two lines of
code you can just copy and paste this
this creates your vector of frequencies
and this shifts then this reorders them
to be consistent with matlab's FFT that
creates this Kappa vector of frequencies
so that each frequency each element of F
has its corresponding frequency that it
corresponds to and now the derivative is
really easy you just take I times Kappa
times F hat and notice this is a dot
times
which does this element-wise
multiplication and then finally all I
have to do is inverse Fourier transform
that and I recover my derivative in real
spacial units and I'm taking the real
part because since these are complex
numbers in the Fourier transform small
machine precision errors can cause the
inverse Fourier transform to be complex
and so you kill any imaginary components
okay pretty simple in MATLAB the the
trick is that it's fast to compute this
FFT it's really easy to make these
vectors of frequencies and it's easy to
compute this derivative and inverse
Fourier transform okay so I'm going to
run all of this code I'm going to run
compute my my data F and it's analytic
derivative I'm going to compute this
using finite differences in MATLAB
that's going to be my benchmark I'm
going to compute the fast Fourier
transform version of the derivative and
then down here I'm going to plot
everything okay and so this is a plot in
white we have the true derivative of
this you know Gaussian envelope cosine
function in yellow we have the finite
difference scheme and in red we have our
FFT derivative it's a little hard to see
here because it's actually all doing
pretty pretty good with this resolution
and on my screen I can see that the
finite difference is is definitely off
and the red curves and white curves are
perfectly overlaying but what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to exaggerate this point
by making my data coarser so instead of
128 points I'm gonna have 64 points so
I'm gonna have a coarser a bigger Delta
X okay and when I do this we should see
a more dramatic change in performance so
now we can actually see that there's a
pretty dramatic difference between the
finite difference is quite off it's it's
off at all points but the red FFT
derivative is almost perfectly aligned
with the true derivative okay and I
might even zoom in a little to show you
this better so even when you zoom in you
see that the white curve which is our
analytic derivative is almost perfectly
aligned with the FFT derivative even
when the finite difference is off so
even if I korsun the data consider
the FFT derivative stays quite accurate
okay so that's really nice
property of the FFT okay good now this
wasn't meant to be really quantitative
or exhaustive sure you could come up
with better finite difference schemes
you could make Delta X smaller you could
do all kinds of things we do talk about
this in the book so you can kind of
check this out
let me find it real quick here it is so
we do talk about this in the book where
what I do is I actually carefully go
through and compute the finite
difference derivative and the spectral
or FFT derivative as I increase the
number of points and which corresponds
to decrease in Delta X so we know that
our finite difference is going to get
better when I make my Delta X smaller
and smaller and smaller but how much
better does it get how fast okay so
that's what this plot shows is the error
in a log plot versus how many data
points I have okay and so you're
absolutely right as I increase the
number of data points my my finite
difference does get more accurate
because Delta X is getting smaller but
it gets more accurate very very slowly
whereas the spectral derivative when I
increase my data points it gets much
much much better much much faster okay
so this is is kind of spectral
convergence that's what we call this as
spectral convergence it's much better
than a finite difference scheme in fact
it's better than any finite difference
scheme you know even if I did central
difference or higher order that would
bring these down but the spectral
derivative is kind of you know
outperforming all of these so this is a
nice in fact I would encourage you to
try to write this code yourself it's
really not that hard you just wrap a for
loop around this whole thing making and
larger and larger and larger and then
you can make these plots yourself you
can try different derivative schemes and
really convince yourself this spectral
derivative is is you know much more
accurate at least on clean data okay the
other thing I want to point out and this
is in also in Chapter two of our book is
you do have to be careful when you're
competing the derivative of functions
even if the your function f is
continuous like this function our
triangular hat function we look
earlier the derivative of this
triangular hat function is discontinuous
I have 0 then the derivative immediately
becomes 1 then it immediately becomes
negative 1 and then it goes back to 0 so
there's these jump discontinuities and
when I use the spectral derivative the
FFT to compute the derivative of this
function because the derivative is
discontinuous I'm going to get these
Gibbs phenomena that I that I saw before
ok so you still can get Gibbs phenomenon
if you're taking the derivative of a
function where the derivative is
discontinuous ok so you have to be
careful and if you see this now you'll
know what you're looking at you're
looking at these Gibbs phenomena because
your derivative function is
discontinuous ok so long story short we
can use the FFT to very very accurately
and rapidly approximate derivatives of
vectors of data and we're going to be
able to use this to solve partial
differential equations ok thank you